هذا واحد من سته فنادق تستاجرها وزاره
الداخليه البريطانيه ليواء اطفال طالبين
لجوء وصلوا عبر البحر الى البلاد من دون
ذويهم عشره من هؤلاء الاطفال اختطفوا من
هذا الشارع وادخلهم الخاطفون في السيارات
عنوه حسب صحيفه الجارديان
وفق الصحيفه فان العصابات الاجراميه لم
تستهدف نزلاء هذا الفندق فحسب بل اختطفت
اطفال اخرين من مدن اخرى على الساحل
الجنوبي لانجلترا حاله من الزهور اصابه
سكان المقيمين في محيط هذه الفنادق
الكثير من الاخفاقات فيما جرى انه امر
مروع وفشل كبير
اذا كانوا يحاولون الذهاب الى مكان اخر كي
يعيش فيه فلنتركهم وشانههم اما اذا كانوا
مختطفين الاستغلالهم فعلينا ان نجدهم ونحل
الامر
في ظروف عاديه
للخوف والقلق اما اختفاءه عشرات الاطفال
الذين لا اهل لهم وفي بلد لا يعرفونه فهو
قضيه تثير اسئله عديده خصوصا انهم وصلوا
هذا الشاطئه بحثا عن حياه افضل
الحكومه البريطانيه تقول انها مضطره الى
ايواء الاطفال في فنادق وتعزوا الامر الى
زياده غير المسبوقه في اعداد طالب اللجوء
معظم المفقودين من الجنسيه الالمانيه وفوق
سن السادسه عشر وقد بدا استخدام الفنادق
لايواء القاصرين منتصف عام 2021
وتتعهد الحكومه بانهائه في وقت قريب
المهاجرين على نظام ايواء طالب اللجوء لم
يكن لدينا بديل من استخدام فنادق متخصصه
لوضع سقف فوق رؤوس القاصرين من دون ذويهم
في الوقت الذي تعمل فيه السلطات المحليه
على ايجاد مسكن لهم
ادفع
عشره المنظمات غير الحكوميه تقول انها
اعربت مرارا وتكرارا عن مخاوفها بشان
اختفاء الاطفال طالبين لجوء من الفنادق
وتؤكد انها عرضت على وزاره الداخليه تقديم
المساعده لكن الحكومه تردد
مصانع الحشيش والاستغلال الجنسي لا نعلم
بالضبط اين يتاجرون بهم ولكن الاستغلال هو
المصير الحكمي لعدد كبير منهم
تتقذف الجهات المعنيه المسؤوليه ما بين
الشرطه ووزاره الداخليه والمجالس المحليه
لكن الكشف بحد ذاته والاقرار الرسمي به
يشكلان صدمه هزه المعنيين بحقوق طالبين
اللجوء في بريطانيا وخارجها محمد المدهون
الجزيره رايتن جنوبيه انجلترا